imaginons le problème résolu quelle
solution vous voyez deux états côte à
côte c'est ça vous savez avec un mur
avec un mur entre les
deux et bonsoir bonsoir donc vous n'êtes
pas ambassadrice de Palestine en France
mais délégué général de Palestine en
France donc vous représentez Yasser
Arafat dans notre pays le peuple
palestinien aussi bien sûr alors vous
êtes né en 1949 à Beyrouth au Liban 1 an
après la création de l'État d'Israël
votre arrière-g-père était maire de
Jérusalem au début du 20e siècle votre
grand-père lui avait été arrêté par les
Anglais après l'échec de la révolte
arabe de 1936 et déporté en rodésie
jusqu'à 1945 voilà il voulait lui
empêcher le partage de la Palestine et
créé un État laïque et binational donc
votre famille a été contraintte de
s'exiler au Liban votre père a été élevé
chez les jésuites votre mère chez les
ququeurs Américains bien que tous les
deux musulmans évidemment et votre
enfance a été bercée par les récits que
votre mère vous faisait de ce pays perdu
et vous racontez que la nuit quand elle
massait votre dos à cause de vos crises
d'asthme elle vous racontait la la
maison familiale de Jérusalem occupée en
1948 par les Israéliens le le jardin les
les jeux d'enfants vous n'y êtes jamais
allé dans cette maison euh dans cette
maison non puisque cette maison
aujourd'hui est occupé par des familles
israéliennes puisqu'elle était à
Jérusalem Ouest mais j'ai été en
Palestine ailleurs dans d'autres lieux
où moi aussi j'ai eu une mémoire puisque
j'ai commencé à à aller en Palestine en
6 jouranie qui n'était pas occupé avant
67 et donc j'ai des souvenirs moi-même
de Jéricho et il y avait une ferme il y
avait une ferme modèle à Jéricho dans
laquelle vous alliez raconé vous avez
vous avez beaucoup lu sur ma vie je vois
oui alors votre premier contact
personnel avec les Israéliens c'est
quand vous aviez 16 ans vous étiez en
pension à Londres avec deux jeunes
filles israéliennes alors pas du tout
pareil il y en a une chaque fois qu'elle
vous voyait elle chantit l'hyne national
israélien pour m'agasser ou piano et
l'autre au contraire vous êtes devenu
assez amis avec elleou alors lare
m'expliquer l'agressivité de la de la
première qui pensait en jouant l'imne
nationale h et je pense que ça a été
absolument mon destin de pouvoir
rencontrer deux genres différents de de
femmes israéliennes pour très vite
comprendre qu'il ne fallait pas voir les
Israéliens de manière monolitique h
alors la date clé de de votre vie c'est
1967 la guerre des 6 jours Israël occupe
le Sinaï le Golan la S Jordanie Gaza
Jérusalem Est euh pour le peuple
palestinien c'est la défaite la honte
l'humiliation tous les Arabes par que
c'est il y a des armées arabes aussi qui
sont concernés qui on eux aussi vivent
ça comme une défaite cuisante ou ouais
et votre engagement politique date de de
cette époque et vous travaillez ensuite
jusqu'à la création de l'OLP avec yasr
Arafat yasr Arafat et vous vous êtes en
contact quotidien vous parlez tous les
jours quotidien c'est beaucoup dire mais
régulièrement oui quotidien c'est
difficile en particulier depuis qu'il
est assiégé actuellement il est en bonne
santé c'est difficile de dire bonne
santé quiconque est assiégé pendant
pratiquement 12 mois et en particul un
monsieur de 72 ans qui n'est pas en
parfaite santé euh euh reçoit le coup il
peut pas marcher il ne peut pas s'aérer
assez il il ne peut pas réellement vivre
une vie normale et donc on on voit la
fatigue alors Ellie Barnavi a dit ici
sur ce plateau il y a quelques semaines
Israël a perdu la guerre des médias euh
parce que quand on voit la télévision un
enfant avec une pierre à la main face à
un char de de tsal évidemment on est
pour l'enfant et et ajoutait-il ce qu'on
sait pas c'est que derrière l'enfant
avec la pierre à la main il y a des
hommes des adultes armés euh qui
poussent l'enfant non je je crois que
les les gens ont regardé ce que la
télévision montre ça veut dire la
réalité en direct une occupation
militaire or Israël occupe militairement
la Palestine avec ses saette population
civile depuis 35 ans Israël est une
puissance occupante et ce n'est jamais
ce n'est jamais bon pour aucun
gouvernement pour aucun État en Israël
comme ailleurs dans le monde ce n'était
pas non plus très bien pour les
Iraquiens d'occuper le K c'est pas une
question de de population autant d'un
fait de réalité politique c'est vrai
quand même que les Palestiniens on
aujourd'hui une meilleure image moi je
me souviens il y a 30 ans c'était la
prise d'otage au Jeux Olympiques de
Munich les Palestiniens avaient vraiment
une image de terroriste terrible alors
qu'aujourd'hui je vous dirais que
c'était une image objective parce que
humunik a eu lieu ce n'était pas
seulement une image c'était une réalité
mais c'est vrai qu'on a occulté le fait
que c'était aussi un peuple maintenant
on voit que c'est tout un peuple qui
résiste contre l'occupation que DEP
depuis trop longtemps alors il y a dans
cette population les personnes armées
les personnes qui ne sont pas armées
mais il y a en face sûrement une des
armées les plus puissante du monde je
voulais juste vous demander si la
Palestine avait la même armée la même
puissance est-ce qu'elle ferait pas la
même chose ah non pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle ferait la même chose puisque
elle ne cherche pas à occuper Israël la
Palestine a été une société arabe avec
des chrétiens des musulmans et des Juifs
il y av une communauté juive c'est
devenu un état israélien qui a
malheureusement pris toute la place de
la Palestine et la Palestine a disparu
aujourd'hui les Palestiniens proposent à
leurs ennemis à leurs bourreau à la
puissance qui les occupe de partager ce
pays en ne réclamant que moins d'un
quart mais nous exigeons aussi d'avoir
le droit d'exister souverain et
souverain et libre je pense queil faut
comprendre la tragédie de deux peuples
qui ont chacun souffert terriblement à
sa manière le peuple israélien aant été
porteur de de la de souvenir du génocide
terrible qu'on vécu les Juifs en Europe
les PAL palestinens se retrouvant un peu
les victimes des victimes mais je crois
que il faut ne pas oublier que ce
conflit comme tous les autres vous
concerne aussi dans le reste du monde à
l'époque où les Palestiniens étaient
peut-être moins considérés par par
l'opinion publique
occidentale vous aviez coutume de dire
vous et puis d'autres Palestiniens ah
ben finalement c'est normal vous vous
sentez coupable par rapport au peuple
juif parce que vous avez cette honte de
la Choa de ce qui s'est passé P la Guer
il y ame quelque chose pou pas non plus
complètement les Palestiniens vous
désengagez de la Choa parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on dit rarement enfin
faut le dire puisque c'est vrai c'est
qu'en 1941 quand même le grand mfti de
Jérusalem est allé voir Hitler à Berlin
et qu'ils ont quand même prévu tous les
deux Hitler lui a dit bon j'ai quelques
problèmes à régler mais après je vous
promets on va s'occuper des Juifs qui
sont en Palestine on pe pas complètement
vous abstraire du problème de la ch non
mais il n'y a jamais eu d'alliance
politique entre les nazis et les
Palestiniens il y a eu comme dans toutes
les toutes les alliances un ennemi
commun qui était l'Angleterre et donc
c'est pour ça que le mfti qui luttait
vous l'avez dit contre la le
colonialisme britannique en Palestine a
pensé qu'il pouv faire des alliances
avec les ennemis dans l'Angleterre mais
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps et il
faut surtout pas mélanger l'histoire de
l'Europe puisque le génocide a lieu en
Europe et l'histoire du monde arabe
alors vous êtes toujours prononcé les
lachaï contre les attentats kamikaz hein
euh Arafat aussi d'ailleurs
officiellement mais il y en a toujours
alors il y a deux solutions soit il est
d'accord en secret soit il est dépassé
par les événements bon je vais vous dire
il est bien sûr dépassé par les
événements surtout il est dépassé par
l'affaiblissement que lui a imposé Ariel
Charon puisque pratiquement il a détruit
tous les moyens d'une Autorité
palestinienne qui était toute jeune et
comment voulez-vous que sans police sans
institution sans même possibilité de de
de sortir de chez soi assiégé Arafat
puisse arrêter ces mouvements mais
surtout ce qui perpétue ces opération
kamikaz comme celle qu'on a vu à betchan
à bisan dans le nord d'Israël c'est les
assassinats des des dirigeants locaux et
auxquels répondent les vengeances de
leurs camarades parce que vous savez que
ceux qui ont attaqué le le siège du
licoude ont dit nous voulons venger
notre dirigeant qui a été assassiné hier
par l'armée israélienne et c'est un
cercle vicieux terrible alors
aujourd'hui l'argument numéro 1 des
Palestiniens pour montrer les objectifs
réels des Israéliens euh c'est la
colonisation ils disent voilà regardez
la preuve qu'il veulent pas qu'on fasse
deux états séparés et tout c'est qu'il y
a une colonisation israélen les
palestinens ne sont pas les seuls qui
les montrent les israéliens qui sont
contre la colonisation aussi manifestent
tous les jours leur opposition à la
création de nouvelles colonies
israéliennes en territoire palestinien
d'accord mais il y a quand même aussi
des des Palestiniens en Israël il y a
quand même 1 million de Palestiniens qui
vivent en Israël sont citoyens
israéliens nous sommes ils sont citoyens
israéliens ils respectent la légalité
israélienne et ils sont citoyens
israéliens depuis 1948 depuis la
création de l'État nous disons aux Juifs
qui veulent vivre dans l'État souverain
palestinien qui sont les bienvenus s'ils
le souhaitent ce que nous rejetons c'est
qu'auj aujourd'hui la colonisation
c'estàd la création de colonies
uniquement pour les citoyens juifs
israéliens dans les territoires
palestiniens elle a un but stratégique
très clair elle veut empêcher la
constitution d'un État palestinien
puisque elle mine ce territoire elle
coupe la continuité géographique de ce
territoire et on fait des bandes t temp
non viablebl pour devenir un jour un
État palestinien puisque la position du
gouvernement actuel du lioude c'est que
il n'y a pas de place pour un État
palestinien dans ce qu'ils appellent le
Grand Israël et donc ils souhaitent que
cet état se fasse ailleurs mais les
Palestiniens ne veulent pas d'état
ailleurs ils le veulent en Palestine à
côté de l'État d'Israël je voulais vous
demander ce
soir vraiment sincèrement avec cette
génération là on parle pas de la
prochaine mais maintenant est-ce que
vous pensez que Elis israélien et les
Palestiniens veulent profondément la
paix est-ce que vous croyez qu'il dans
la société israélienne il y a déjà au
moins plus de 50 % qui souhaitent la
paix et qui réalise même les
statistiques le disent les son sondage
disent que plus de 60 % voudrai voir un
État palestinien voudrait la suite des
négociations mais il y a 60 % qui
veulent soutenir Charon donc il y a une
contradiction parce qu'il y a
fondamentalement un désarroi chez les
Palestiniens il y a 70 % qui sont contre
les opérations kamikaz et il y a 70 %
qui veulent que nous reprenions les
négociations politiques mais il faut que
vous sachiez que Ariel Charon ne croit
pas dans la négociation politique
dites-moi l est-ce que vous en voulez
aux États arabes de la région oui qui la
DEP PAL la misre et qui util le
désespoir comme unee par le peuple
palestinien est instrumentalis dir pas
qu'ils utilisent ils sont
instrumentalisés par certains mais on
peut pas dire en général par tous les
Arabes premièrement il faut faire une
différence PAL oui mais laissez-moi vous
dire ils nous ont donné souvent beaucoup
d'argent qu'on n pas toujours su bien
utiliser mais disons qu'il faut faire
une différence entre les population
Arabes et les États les régimes les
gouvernements au niveau des populations
je crois qu'il y a une sincère
adhésion totale pas parce qu'on est
arabe parce que nous sommes le cas
flagrant d'une injustice au 20e siècle
que nous n'avons pas mérité nous n'avons
rien fait contre les Juifs nous n'avons
même rien fait contre les Israéliens
aujourd'hui on les fait souffrir mais
pendant 50 ans nous n'avons rien fait
contre même les israëlien mais par
contre au niveau des régimes il y a bien
sûr une très grande je dirais incapacité
d'être efficace alors il y a ceux qui
veulent mais qui ne savent pas comment
faire il y a ceux qui ne veulent pas
mais le résultat est le même ça veut
dire que nous sommes déçus nous sommes
déçus sur le plan politique avant tout
après tout le monde arabe compte 22
États qui qui doivent peser ce que je
veux dire ce que je veux dire les La
Chal c'est que si l'Arabie Saoudite et
les États arabes de la région aider la
Palestine comme les États-Unis et
d'Israël le peuple palestinien serait
pas dans cet état on le demande même pas
ça nous demandons aux États arabes
d'avoir une position unie de défense du
droit et des résolutions des Nations
Unies pas plus mais de dire à leurs
alliés américains parce qu'ils sont tous
alliésord avec les Américains et avec
les Européens que ils ne continueront
pas cette alliance si justice n'est pas
rendue et si le droit n'est pas appliqué
c'est tout ce qu'on demand il font pas
pour le moment ils ne sonont pas parce
qu'il ils ne se mettent pas d'accord
ensemble parce que il y a des
divergences parce que ils n'arrivent pas
à assumer leur fonction que les États
européens assumé d'être une puissance
régionale comme l'UR alors imaginons le
problème résolu quelle solution vous
voyez deux états côte à côte c'est ça
vous savez avec un m avec un mur entre
les deux pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
été sur oui ce sont deux peuples qui par
beaucoup d'Aspet se ressemblent beaucoup
qui sont dans un territoire très exigu
qui sont les voisins du Liban de
l'Égypte de la Jordanie j'imagine très
bien que deux États peuvent vivre côte à
côte chacun ayant le soutien aussi de
son environnement naturel donc nous on
aura le soutien aussi des États arabes
mais un jour je peux imaginer tout à
fait comme l'Europe une confédération
une fédération d'État qui permettra
finalement à Israël aussi de se
retrouver dans un environnement Cordi
qui la reconnaît avec quelle elle peut
faire un un du commerce des échanges
nous étions pas très loin de ça au
moment où Rabine a été assassiné
peut-être justement a-t-il été assassiné
par ce qui ne souhaite pas qu'Israël
finalement ai devienne un état normal en
pai avec vous dites c'est ce que disait
Ellie Barnavi ici donc c'est donc l'OLP
ne veut pas jeter les Juifs à la mer
absolument pas elle l'a jamais voulu
dans ce cas-là vous voyez Jérusalem
comme une ville partagée en deux inter
vous connaissz Jérusalem vous connaissez
Jérusalem c'est une ville unique ma mère
est née t mes aussi c'est une ville qui
mérite de devenir une ville universelle
de la paix et si elle devient un jour
cette ville non divisée toujours uni qui
est la la capitale de deux états de deux
peuples de vous tous de tout ce qui
réunit le monde ça veut dire leur
humanité elle sera à la hauteur de son
histoire et moi personnellement je pense
qu'elle deviendra un jour une ville
universelle de paix souonsle
vraiment n pas ce n'est pas de
l'utopie
alors pour y arriver faut négocier comme
dit Amram m qui est le le leader nouveau
leader du Parti travailliste israélien
il dit Arafat est notre ennemi mais
c'est avec nos ennemis que nous devons
faire la paix Rabine disait la même
chose exactement oui et nous pensons
nous nous n'aimons pas particulièrement
Monsieur Charon mais nous disons si
Charon est le le le le dirigeant qui
représente la majorité démocratique des
Israéliens nous nous négocierons avec
lui parce qu'il faut négocier avec son
ennemi vous avez travaillé sur les camps
euh de Sabra et Chatila en tant que
sociologue à un moment de de votre vie
que je connais un peu vous connaissez
beaucoup de choses sur oui alors euh
Sabra et Chatila on accuse toujours
Ariel Charon d'avoir commis lui-même les
massacres vous savez très bien les les
les Israéliens n'ont rien fait mais les
massacres ont été commis par les milices
chrétienes libanaises Riit rien fait
c'est beaucoup dire parce que maintenant
que les langues se délient parce que
l'histoire permet du recul et qu'on dise
les choses euh toutes les commissions
d'enquête et tous les écrivains inclus
beaucoup de soldats israéliens très
courageux disent que l'armée Israël a
été en charge d'encadrer de diriger
d'organiser ce massacre puisque Charon
disait lui-même je vais combattre les
terroristes et nettoyer berou des
terroristes sauf qu'il n'y avait plus de
combattants alors est-ce que vous pensez
que Infiné euh l'Intifada est une bonne
chose pour les Palestiniens vous
connaissez Abou Mazen oui bien sûr Abou
Abou maen a déclaré que la deuxième
Intifada était une erreur qui a engagé
le peuple palestinien sur une voie de
destruction desésacquis et que
finalement c'est un échec à long terme
moi je vous diraai vous avez dit que je
suis sociologue je pense que
l'untifad'est une décision de personne
c'est un mouvement social c'est un
mouvement de résistance civile d'une
population entière qui est saturée
d'humiliation de misère d'oppression et
et et et surtout de de manque de liberté
et que ce n'est ni la décision de Yas
Arafat ni celle d'Abou maen les les
citoyens lorsqu'ils résistent il
demandent la permission de personne ce
que abouzen essaie de dire c'est qu'il
fallait pas militariser cette cette
révolte cette résistance soulèvement par
faut que je vous dise que infada en
arabe ça veut dire se relever ça veut
dire relever le mentau reprendre
confiance en soi reprendre sa dignité ce
n'est pas contre quelqu'un mais c'est
par rapport à soi-même estce que vous
avez déjà rencontré Ariel Charon non
j'ai rencontré Monsieur Barac j'ai
rencontré Monsieur PZ j'ai rencontré
Monsieur
Rabine je n'ai pas rencontré
monsieuronz Dariel Charon vous lui
diriez quoi je lui dirais que si
vraiment c'est un patriote israélien il
mène son peuple vers un suicide parce
que le choix militaire qu'il a pris son
refus de dialogue et de négociation
politique ne peut mener son peuple qu'à
un suicide que ce serait tragique
surtout s'il veut que l'histoire se
rappelle de lui comme l'homme qui a
donné à Israël une vie à l'avenir on et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu